[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد المنطقه على
موعد مع تصعيد ياخذ بها الى حرب كبيره
هكذا جاء تحضير اداره الاستخبارات
العسكريه بالجيش الاسرائيلي التي اتهمت
الامين العام لحزب الله حسن نصر الله
باقترابه من ارتكاب خطا اني قد يتسبب
بوقوع حرب واسعه وذكرت وكاله الانباء
الالمانيه عن صحيفه تايمزوفيسرائيل نقلا
عن مدير الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
اهارون حليفه ان تصعيد الذي حدث في
الاسابيع الاخيره على الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه ربما لم ينتهي بالنسبه لحسن نصر
الله تصريحات المسؤوله الاسرائيلي تاتي
عقب تنفيذ ميليشيا حزب الله مناورات
عسكريه غير مسبوقه كما وصفت في الجنوب
اللبناني امام وسائل الاعلام حيث اشار
مدير الاستخبارات العسكريه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى ان الطريقه للتعامل مع هذا
التهديد قد تكون باستخدام القوه بطريقه
مدروسه ومحسوبه المنا التي اجرتها ميليشيا
حزب الله من الاحد في منطقه عرمه جنوب
لبنان اخذت حيزا من الاهتمام اللبناني حيث
اعتبرها معارضوها تعد على السياده
اللبنانيه فيما وصف مسؤولون في ميليشيا
حزب الله هذه المنوره بانها رساله ثبات
وجهزيه لتعلم اسرائيل والعالم ان مقاومه
حزب الله ليست مقاومه عابره وفق قولهم
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من بيروت على
الامين رئيس تحرير موقع جنوبيه من نيويورك
طوني بدران الباحث في مركز الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام اسمحوا
لي ان ابدا من الداخل اللبناني وبالتحديد
معك استاذ علي الامين لنفهم المراد من هذا
التحرك العسكري لحزب الله هل الرساله اللي
داخله من الخارج
يعني خلينا نقول اولا تحياتي لك ولضيفك
وللمشاهدين العربيه
بالتاكيد
بالشكل خلينا نقول هي مناسبه ذكرى التحرير
حصل هذا يعني هذه المناورات
ب 25 عيار التحرير الامر الثاني كما يعني
صار معروفا انه هذا غير مسبوق وهو ربما
بعض المقربين من حزب الله يعني اشاروا الى
انه وكانها رساله ضمنيه تدل على الخروج من
سوريا وهذا محل نقاش ما بدي اقف عنده كثير
ما في شك ان هذا الامر له وظيفه داخليه
وظيفه خارجيه الوظيفه الخارجيه نذكر نحن
في ظل الهجمه الاسرائيليه على غزه الاخيره
والتي ادت الى اغتيال اكثر من 13 قياده من
الجهاد الاسلامي لاحظ الكثيرون ان حزب
الله لم يبدي اي حراك في وقت كان امين عام
حزب الله تحدث عن وحده الساحات
فبالتالي في محاوله تعويضيه بمكان ما بهذا
هذه المناوره التي حصلت وهي
تحدث الاسرائيليون عن خطا هل ممكن انه
يستغلوا خطا ما
ولكن
حزب الله بده حرب
لا نعلم ان كانت
باشاره لهذه التطورات في داخل لبنان او هي
تشير بها الى طرف اخر سيطوني مثلا رايس
الاسرائيلي اليوم قال سنفاجئ
الجميع او سنفاجئ اعدائنا هكذا قال لا
نعلم ان كان يتحدث عن حزب الله ان يتحدث
عن طرف اخر ولكن بعض ربطها بهذه المناورات
لحزب الله
مساء الخير
التنشيل التصريح رئيس الوزراء على جنب شوي
في بتصور انا ادقها تصريح هو كان من رئيس
الاركان الاسرائيلي
يلي قال في انه
حزب الله
يعتقد انه هو يفهم كيف نفكر نحن وبالتالي
يعني كيف سنرد او لن نرد على
مناورات الحزب اوت تحركات الحزب في الداخل
مثلا نعيد بلشنا نشوفها خصوصا منذ العام
بالداخل الاسرائيلي ومع الملف الفلسطيني
تحديدا ثم مع في الملف التقسيم البحري
الحدود البحريه مع النعم بالتالي كان في
عده نقاط يعني ساهمت ببناء هالنظره او
هالتصور
لمعادله الردع كما يسميها بحزب بينه وبين
اسرائيل وصلت اخيرا مؤخرا
بالشهر الماضي مش بس انه الاطلاق صواريخ
بكميات اكبر كمان بعمليه من الداخل
اللبناني في الداخل الاسرائيلي اللي هي
عمليه
ذكره حليفه
انما تصريح رئيس الاركان قال انه الحزب
كان عم بياخذ عم بيقوم بخطوات في اماكن
يظن انها لن تقود الى حرب انما
قد يتم قد يتفاجا يعني اذا ضلوا ماشي
وهذه
موازيه لتصريح حليبه يلي عم بيقول انه
عمليه ماده ليست الاخيره يعني في يمكن
معلومات استخباراتي عن تخطيط لعمليه منها
النوع فيها السياق يجري من ال2021 يلي لم
يتم الرد عليه
من هنا تاتي المخاوف على اثر هذه القراءات
تقول البعض سيد علي بانه الوضع قابل
الانفجار حضرتك تقول بانه هذه المناورات
اقتصرت على بقعه جغرافيه لم تتخطى عرمت
ولكن ان تخطط او ان تطورت قد ينفلت
الموضوع وكيف سيكون تداعيات كل هذا
بالتاكيد يعني انا عم بقول انه حزب الله
ما بيقوم بحرب ممكن يعني يقوم ببعض
العمليات لكن دائما محسوبه باطار ان لا
تستدرج حربا كبيره وربما يعني بمعنى ما
كما يقال انه قد لا يعني قد يخطئ في مكان
ما ويؤدي الى تؤدي الامور الى حرب لانه
ما بده حرب لانه اساسا امكانيه قيام حرب
وقدره لبنان على تحمل فكره حرب مع اسرائيل
في هذه المرحله الكل يعلم انه الظروف كلها
ليست مساعده لامكانيه ان يكون لبنان في
موقع متماسك يعني لاقتصاديا لماليا وهذا
امرته حزب الله ادرى في في هذه الامور
وحزب الله يدرك ثمن السلطه التي يمتلكها
اليوم في لبنان وهو لا يريد ايضا ان يغامر
بهذه السلطه بالتالي هو يحاول ان يقدم
نفسه دائما من عنوان انه جهه مقا تقاتل
اسرائيل وبنفس الوقت يقدم نفسه ايضا
للمجتمع الدولي بطريقه اخرى وهذا ايضا
رايناه عن ترسيم الحدود البحريه انه ضامن
للاستقرار في هذه المنطقه اعتقد الى حد
كبير حزب الله لن يغامر بهذه ولكن مع
المحافظه على الشكل لانه قوه مقاومه هل
تقبل اسرائيل بهذا بهذا الامر
وتتجاوزه يبقى الامر عند الاسرائيليين هل
تقبل اسرائيل هل يقبل او كيف يقبل الدخل
اللبناني مثل هكذا منورات حضرتك تقول بانه
حزب الله يسيطر على السلطه ولكن له شركاء
سيد طوني اين الاطراف السياسيين الاخرين
في داخل اللبناني من كل ما يحدث
هو اصلا الحكومه هو فيها وهو
بتصور مساله الداخل اللبناني
هيدا حديث بين
بين الحزب وبين اسرائيل خصوصا لانه صار في
عندنا مشكله من ال2021 لليوم انه الحزن
اخذ حريه اخرى صحيح قد نناقش تداعياتها
والتطورات هذه المناورات لاحقا شكرا جزيلا
لك طوني بدران وكذلك شكر لضيفي علي
الامينه السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات